what's up everybody its Warren and today
we have a video of Natasha and the Hulk
reuniting on the battlefield something
that was never addressed in Avengers
infinity war or Avengers end game was
the relationship that Black Widow and
the Hulk had in the past yeah I'm back
hi Bruce
but as it turns out there was actually
versions of the movie that did address
this and now one of the scenes has been
revealed not only does this deleted
scene from Avengers infinity war show
The Hulk coming out in the movie but it
shows him reuniting with Black Widow as
well where she attempts to calm him down
like she does in Avengers age of Ultron
so let's break down this deleted scene
shot-for-shot I'm still doing an xbox
one and ps4 giveaway all you have to do
to enter is subscribe when notifications
turned on like the video and comment
below so this new scene starts out with
the same scene from Avengers infinity
war where Bruce Banner is in the
Hulkbuster and he is fighting cool
Obsidian although this time it goes
quite differently than the version that
we saw in theaters for Avengers infinity
war as Bruce Banner is fighting coal
obsidian in the Hulkbuster armor and is
losing he starts to talk to the Hulk and
we hear the same thing that we heard in
Avengers infinity war where he says Hulk
I know you like to make your appearance
at the last minute well this is it if
you were going to be popping out at any
moment this is the time and in this
scene it's actually really really cool
we get to see the Hulk inside of the
Hulkbuster armor and Bruce Banner inside
of the Hulkbuster armor as well and we
get to see them kind of talk back and
forth together like we're inside of
their head but they're actually speaking
out loud and then we see Hulk say no
banner only wants the Hulk for fighting
and Banner replies so what'd you like to
fight but then we go back to the Hulk
and he says banner hate Hulk and this is
kind of like the scene that we got from
Thor Ragnarok where Thor is talking to
the Hulk and the Hulk says earth hates
Hulk
so clearly the Hulk has some sensitivity
issues here however Banner replies to
the Hulk by saying you're more of an
Avenger than I am I love you
Hulk replies I just want to live and
banner says me too man then the Hulk
says me too banner says ok so let's live
then he says ok let's live and let live
yes live and let live Banner then says I
got an idea and they go back to fighting
coal obsidian and they start to fight
and they start to lose again to coal
obsidian but then we see inside of their
helmet and banners eyes open up and then
we see professor Hulk or smart Hulk as
he's referred to in Avengers endgame and
we hear him say we worked it out and
this was actually supposed to be the
first time that we saw a professor Hulk
and Avengers Infinity Ward not an
Avengers end game and it ends pretty
much the same exact way that it does in
Avengers infinity war with coal obsidian
attacking the Hulk Buster and the Hulk
and Bruce Banner sending him off lined
by the repulsor blaster but then we cut
to a scene of Professor Hulk outside of
the Hulkbuster armor this is where smart
Hulk sees himself for the very first
time he goes over to a pool of water and
looks at his reflection and then we go
to another scene where Black Widow and
Falcon are running through the woods
they come out of the woods and they stop
because they see professor Hulk walking
out of the woods as well
Black Widow takes a look at him and says
look who finally decided to show up and
then she extends her hand much like the
very same way that she did in Avengers
age of Ultron and she says the Suns
getting real low big guy and this was
the big thing from Avengers age of
Ultron Black Widow finally figured out
how to get Bruce Banner to come back
after he transformed into the Hulk so
she goes to do it again after not seeing
him for many many years expecting it to
work but after she says this we see
professor Hulk and he just says hello
NAT Natasha it looks completely floored
she is just in shock and she says Bruce
professor Hulk Vince says we worked it
out and he goes on to say we've went
from worst case scenario to I'm not
gonna say best case scenario but
manageable she turns around and looks to
Falcon and Falcon looks back at her and
says I hear it too so you can tell that
Black Widow is just in complete shock by
what she's seen right now she then turns
around and looks back at him and we get
a shot of the two of them just simply
staring at each other and you can just
tell that all of the feelings that
they've once had for each other are
still there and they've come back and
they still really really care for one
another which of course becomes very
apparent and Avengers in game win of
course she dies and professor Hulk is
just absolutely beaten up about it he
even tries to bring her back when he
snaps his fingers but unfortunately
because she sacrificed herself for the
soulstone he could not now although I
would have loved to have seen this scene
in Avengers infinity war I would have
loved to see the Hulk and Black Widow
reconnect the reason why they did not
end up including this an infinity war is
very apparent this would have completely
changed the way that Avengers in game
went with introducing professor Hulk and
ultimately they decided to leave it out
to have Avengers in game go the way that
it did but what do you
would you have rather had this an
Avengers infinity war and had Avengers
endgame go a little bit differently with
how they introduced professor Hulk's
since he already would have been
introduced or are you happy with the way
things played out let me know which way
you prefer in the comments down below
and again I'm still doing my ps4 and
Xbox giveaway the winner gets to choose
which one they would like all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel with the notifications turned on
leave a like on the video and drop a
comment down below and if you'd like a
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet you
can follow me on twitter and click the
link down below as well as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll fluff